MonkaW!
Was bei Amazon gibt es?
Hat jemand von euch den Amazon 55 Zoll Fernseher für 199 Euro gekauft?
Ach die Jacht?
Ne der muss bestimmt wieder ins Weltall fliegen
Ja es gab einen 55 Zoll Fernseher für 199 Euro heute morgen angeblich
Der hat normalerweise 699 Euro gekauft
Das ist so ein Fire TV Ding
Beiss und iGamble 0
Dankeschön für den Sub
Ich habe noch nie so viel Geld gekauft
iGamble 0 Dankeschön für den Sub
Pog
Extremly Pog
Nice
Echt gibt es den?
Das Fire TV Ding hat eingebaute
Mikrofone und alles
Ich weiß nicht ob ich das mal in die Forderung stellen will
Aber ich meine
199 Dollar ist eindeutig sehr preisgünstig
55 Zoll Fernseher
Ansonsten war das natürlich nicht
Super High End
Kann man auch nicht erwarten
Du wirst Arch auf deinem Surface Go
Und es wird Arch die Beste
So muss das sein
Auf Notebooks, also wenn du es im Notebook Betrieb machen willst
Da musst du bei Linux immer ein bisschen gucken
Dass die ganzen
Energiespar Sachen
Funktionieren
Falls du irgendwelche besonderen
Hersteller Tools brauchst kann es sein
Dass es das unter Linux nicht gibt
Aber so im Großen und Ganzen funktioniert das
Mittlerweile erstaunlich gut wenn man das mal mit früher vergleicht
Das ist ein Fernseher mit integriertem
Fire TV Studio
Ja trotzdem 199 Euro
Für den
55 Zoll Fernseher ist trotzdem nicht schlecht
Trinken nicht vergessen
Ne ich hab hier ganze
Tasse neue
Frisch Tee
Und wie war es bei euch heute so Chat
Oh ich muss mal die Klimaanlage anmachen jetzt ist übelst warm
Was war bei euch heute los
Irgendwas Spannendes passiert
War warm
Ich hab gehört bei uns im Büro war es 21 Grad
Mit Klimaanlage
Das ist schon fast zu kalt
Da schlägt sich direkt
Du weißt du kommst raus und so BÄM
Es haut dich gleich wieder zurück
Wenn du 21 Grad gewohnt bist
Ich muss mal kurz meine VM anmachen
Jo
Also ich mach mal kurz die VM an
Und mach mal Update
Als Fachinformatiker
Anwendungsentwickler
Durch ein Praktikum
In Sales
Dazu kann ich nur sagen
Sales
Was musst du da machen
In dem Praktikum
Du musst hoffentlich nicht wirklich mit Kunden
Reden oder sowas
Und vor allem was erhoffen die sich denn davon
So nach dem Motto
Oh dann kennt er unsere geilen Verkaufsprozesse
Da entwickelt er bestimmt bessere Software
Oh guck mal Leute
Mein Icon Theme wird geupdated
Vielleicht krieg ich wieder ein gescheites
Icon
Für meine JetBrains Toolbox
Du hast demnächst eine Schulung
Zu YubiKey
Muss man da groß was schulen
Okay
Was ist Odo
Ist das ein Ticketsystem oder
Oder sowas in der Richtung
Radiant Tracer
Hat eingestellt für den Sub
Das ist bestimmt so eine Art Ticketsystem oder
Kenn ich nicht
Kann man danach suchen
Odo
Oh
ERPCRM
Okay alles klar
Da weißt du Bescheid
Na Chat
Es ist
Je nachdem wie groß die Firma ist
Ist es nicht verkehrt das zu kennen
Aber ansonsten ganz ehrlich
Musst du als Anwendungsentwickler
Nichts mit den Sales Leuten zu tun haben
Die Zahlen
Im Durchschnitt so gesehen
Oder Anteil mäßig
Große Läden
Mehr Gehalt als kleine Läden
So mal kurz Rebooten
Und hoffen das ich jetzt ein gescheites
JetBrains Icon hab
Ja da kann ich dir auch nicht helfen
Also ich sammle schon ewig
Nichts mehr
Und in Nürnberg kenn ich mich auch nicht aus
So mal gucken ob ich
Jetzt wieder ein gescheites Icon hab
Firefox
Rege
Ah
Nein
Warum
Warum habt ihr so ein gutes Icon ausgetauscht
Das ist so ein hässliches
Keckel
Wir können einfach auch Amazon
Hier mit Firefox unter Linux aufmachen
Wir müssen das gar nicht unter Windows machen
Mir sogar noch lieber
Ordentliches Betriebssystem am Start
Cookies accepten
Kannst du das nicht in den Settings
Vom Launcher ändern
Nee nee das Icon Theme
Was ich verwende hat halt jetzt ein
Icon vermutlich
Also ich geh davon aus dass mein
Icon Theme kein
Custom Icon hatte für die JetBrains Toolbox
Und die jetzt eins hinzugefügt haben
So wie bei Joplin
Die haben auch kein Icon dafür
Und dann nimmt es das Default Icon
Sobald es halt ein Icon gibt
Dann zeigt er das an
Das Problem ist nur dass das neue Icon halt viel hässlicher aussieht
Als das alte
Beziehungsweise als das Default Icon
Vermute ich
Lass mal kurz checken was wir uns heute
Für eine Kategorie mal geben
Also
Also wenn es eins gibt was man
Nicht genug haben kann dann sind es
SSDs
Und Werkzeuge
Lass uns mal kurz
Wifi Geschichten durchgucken
Werkzeuge
Kategorie ist immer nice
Mal gucken ob es was günstig gibt
Ich will nicht Rocks oder so haben
Ich will die Werkzeug Kategorie
In welcher Kategorie sind
Dann Werkzeuge Baumarkt
Oder eher
In Mädchen Mode
Wo sind denn Werkzeuge drunter
Haushalt und Wohnen
Vielleicht ich hätte jetzt eher gesagt
Getippt auf Baumarkt
Ja anscheinend Baumarkt
Warum ist das eigentlich so pepega
Die Anzeige mittlerweile
Hatten die nicht früher
Angebote unter 20 Euro
Okay da können wir mal gucken
Blitzangebote im Trend
Computer und Software
Küche und Haushalt
Möbel
Baumarkt und Garten
Ja exzellent
Ne jetzt ist er schon wieder
Ist das so kacke gemacht
Das beste aus do it yourself
Garten
Wenn es das beste ist
Mal gespannt was das beste ist
Ich hab erst gedacht es ist
Ein Wera Set weil es so grün ist
Aber es ist irgendein billig Zeug
Chat bei euch
Irgendwas Spannendes passiert heute
SanDisk
Extreme 4TB
300 Euro
Ist das ne externe
Festplatte
Hackweightest du dich selber
Du wolltest den Vice hackweighten
Einer meiner Bewerber hat uns
Ausgelacht als er unsere Gehaltsvorstellung
Gehört hat
Jetzt ist die Frage
Wer von euch
Lacked critical information
Der Bewerber
Oder ihr
Wir
Du kannst ihm wahrscheinlich auch nicht mehr geben
Weil budgettechnisch
Gibt nichts oder wie ist das
Darf man mal
Ich weiß ja nicht was du hier liegen willst
Und was nicht
Was
Was für ne range
Habt ihr denn und was sucht ihr denn
Ich weiß wir haben uns
Letztens irgendwas zusammen mal angeschaut
Aber ich kann mich nicht mehr dran erinnern
Ich vermute mal ihr sucht irgendjemand
Mit ein bisschen Berufserfahrung
IT-Technisch und halt irgendwelche Sachen die man aktuell braucht
Was habt ihr denn für ne Gehaltsspanne
Das muss sich ja nicht so auf
Ein Euro festlegen
Ich kanns ja sagen
50 bis 80k oder so
Das ist dann im Prinzip auch
Ja
50 bis 70k
Ja ok
Da kann man verstehen
50 ist halt schon krass wenig
Aber
Für 70 kränkt man vielleicht den ein oder anderen
Aber für ne ordentliche Senior Position
Muss man sagen
Ja jetzt
Findest wahrscheinlich Leute die es dafür machen
Aber
Bestimmt auch genauso viele die dafür keinen Bock haben
Oder mehr die dafür keinen Bock haben
Gerade wenn man sich überlegt
Das die letzten Jahre alles mega teuer geworden ist
Du kannst ja fast die Gehälter von vor 3 Jahren
Nicht mal mit den aktuellen vergleichen
Ja das stimmt
Es kommt ein bisschen drauf an was die Leute drunter verstehen
Ostdeutschland
Ja ok
Gegenangebot
Das sind die Leute blöd
Es ist eh das beste
Also
Verhandlungstechnisch
Ist das beste
Auf die Frage
Umgedreht
Also wenn es irgendwie ums Gehalt geht
Dann ist immer besser
Wenn ihr zuerst was sagt
Klingt jetzt blöd
Ja
Weil man sich dann denkt so nach dem Motto
Ob ihr daneben liegt
Das macht aber nichts
Das ist egal
Ob ihr daneben liegt oder nicht
Die werden es euch schon sagen wenn ihr daneben liegt
Aber dann hat man erstmal
Ne Diskussionsgrundlage
Und da fällt es der anderen Seite
Deutlich schwieriger zu sein
Stellt euch mal vor
Ihr sagt als erstes
Wir nehmen jetzt mal Ami Gehälter
Und die Amis
Die sind ja alle irgendwie 200k plus oder so
Hab ich das Gefühl ab ner gewissen Stufe
Als Softwareentwickler
Wenn das einer sagt dort im Vorstellungsgespräch
Da können die jetzt nicht mal ankommen
Ach ne wir wollen aber doch bloß 50k bezahlen
Da wissen die gleich
Gibt's nicht
Oder auch bei uns
Wenn ihr denen gleich sagt 90k
Da kommen die nicht mit 40 an
Also taktisch ist es immer am besten
Ihr sagt irgendwas
Oder wie hat mal jemand gesagt
Ich hab vor ner ganzen Weile
Irgend so ein Video auf Youtube geguckt
Wo einer erklärt hat
Wenn ihr das erste Angebot abgebt
Was für ne Zahl soll man dann sagen
Und das hab ich mir gemerkt
Im Hinterkopf
Er hat in diesem Video gesagt
Das erste Angebot muss immer kurz vor unverschämt sein
Weiß nicht mehr welches Video das gewesen ist
Schon ewig her
Seh ich auch so
Vor allem die werden euch sagen wenn das nicht reinpasst
Die können immer sagen
Es machen alle Seiten
Ihr sagt 90k
Dann sagen die anderen
Oder irgendwie sowas
Und dann sagen die was
Und dann könnt ihr sagen
Und dann sagen sie
Ja aber bei uns gibt's auch Obstkörbe
Und dann sagt der Keg
Ich hau mal ganz schnell ab hier
Da bin ich mir nicht zu sicher
Weil Homeoffice nicht automatisch 100% Homeoffice heißt
Also ich mein
Die wenigsten Unternehmen
Gerade ab ner gewissen Größe
Wenn's nicht ein super krasser Startup Zeug ist
Die sonst nix finden und super agil alles online
Die wenigsten Unternehmen sind 100% Homeoffice
Und dementsprechend
Brauchst du Leute aus der Region
Und Leute aus der Region wollen dahin
Ich mein die Leute aus der Region sind natürlich frei
Sich auf eine 100% Homeoffice Stelle
Bei irgendeinem US Unternehmen
Zu bewerben und dann
50k zu bekommen oder so
Aber realistisch betrachtet
Werden sich die meisten
Auf irgendwas bewerben was bei ihnen um die Ecke ist
Und dort gibt's halt auch kein 100% Homeoffice
Sodass sich auch jetzt nicht irgendwie
Ganz Deutschland Leute bewerben werden
Ja also so ganz
Ist es nicht egal
Ok Moment was
Was sagt da Tommy
Ich bin jetzt bis März an die Uni gegangen
Um als Hilfskraft zu arbeiten
Jetzt sagt das Unternehmen
Dem ich abgelehnt habe
Ach hast du nicht mal was erzählt
Dass das die sind die dich gebated haben die ganze Zeit
Warst du das?
Oder dass du die gebated hast
Nee die haben dich gebated
Ja dem ich abgelehnt habe
Weil ich
Das sind die die dich mit falschem Namen angeschrieben haben
Und sowas gell
Ja Sonix du fährst da aber auch nicht zweimal in der Woche hin
Oder einmal in der Woche
Dem ich abgelehnt weil ich nicht länger
In der Antwort warten konnte
Dass die mich doch unbedingt haben wollen bis März warten
Wollen bis ich aus dem Univertrag wieder raus bin
Das halte ich für
Ultrasass
Und ich frage mich was mit der Firma da nicht stimmt
Wenn sie so lange aufwohnen
Naja die können ja ein Angebot machen
Was du nicht ablehnen kannst
Einfach so random was kündigen würde ich nicht
Die können ja ein so gutes Angebot machen
Dass ihr sagt
Let's go
Aber werden sie wahrscheinlich nicht
Ich glaube dass es im Vorfeld nicht geklappt hat
Was sagt man wenn man weniger will
Als man gerade hat
Äh
Diese Situation hatte ich noch nie
Ok lass mal überlegen
Du willst weniger
Dann sag das einfach
Da wird doch keiner was dagegen haben
Dann sag einfach
Oder sag ey
Spende die Hälfte von meinem Gehalt
Was auch immer
Keine Ahnung
Was dir dagegen hat wenn du weniger haben willst
Ich geb dir nen Tipp übrigens
Wenn du weniger haben willst
Sag nicht dass du weniger haben willst
Sondern geh einfach Teilzeit arbeiten
Warum gehst du nicht einfach Teilzeit arbeiten
Dann kriegst du weniger
Sag einfach
Du willst nur noch 80, 70 was auch immer wieviel Prozent arbeiten
Dass du auf das kommst
Wo du weniger haben willst
Ja
Ich könnte es mir übrigens vorstellen
Woran das liegt Radiosignale
Ähm
Willst du Kindergeld
Ne wie heißt das
Doch Erziehungsgeld
Das wo sie jetzt runter geregelt haben
Auf 150k
Mit 2 Ehepartnern zusammen
Mit Partnern zusammen
Anstatt 300k
Willst du Elterngeld
Liegt drüber
Paar Euro
Ja da geh einfach Teilzeit arbeiten
Dann kriegst du weniger Geld easy
Wer sagt das
Also ich kann dir sagen ich hab damals angefangen
Ja ähm also
Ne
Doch
2007, 2008
Ja also ich hab damals angefangen
Mit 33.500
So und das ist jetzt sagen wir mal
Ne 15, 2007 hab ich mit der Ausbildung angefangen
Ja doch komm
Das sind 15 Jahre
Mit 15 Jahren
Hab ich mit 33.500 angefangen
Also sprich das was sie mir hier gegeben haben
Und es war damals schon nicht der Wahnsinn
Also sprich das hier ist wahrscheinlich
Inflationsangepasst so ungefähr
Das gleiche
Wahrscheinlich sogar ein bisschen weniger
Ja
Aber in der heutigen Zeit ganz ehrlich
Gehälter von vor 3 Jahren kann man schon fast nicht mehr mit
Vergleichen das die letzten 3 Jahre ist irgendwie
Immer im zweistelligen
Bereich alles teurer geworden
Das sagen die nicht
Wenn es drum geht und wie sind so ihre Vorstellung
Du sagst 90k
Dann werden die nicht auf ich mein die haben dich doch eingeladen
Weil das Profil halbwegs passt
Und wenn es bis zur Gehaltsvorstellung kommt
Da muss man sich soweit ja auch ganz gut verstanden haben
Beziehungsweise so auf dem gemeinsamen
Nenner irgendwie sein
Wenn du sagst 90k und denen ihre Schmerzgrenze
Ist keine Ahnung 80k dann sagen die dir das
Die sagen dir vielleicht nicht direkt
Unsere Schmerzgrenze ist 80k
Die sagen dann so vielleicht
Das passt nicht in unser Gehaltsgefüge
Oder irgendwas
Keine Ahnung
Irgendwelche random Dinger
Um das ein bisschen runter zu handeln
Dann kommen sie wahrscheinlich an mit 70k
Ja dann kannst du dann
Sagen
Ah das ist jetzt aber schon kritisch
Da verdiene ich jetzt ja weniger als
Früher und das
Wenn ich wechsel will man sich auch mal ein bisschen verbessern
Ja okay
Sag mal 85k
Irgendwie kommt der
Also ganz ehrlich es schmeißt sich doch keiner raus
Nur weil du ein bisschen
Über ihrer Schmerzgrenze bist
Das wäre auch einfach komplett pipi
Und wenn sie es machen
Dann ist wahrscheinlich ihre Schmerzensgrenze
So niedrig und so weit von dem weg
Was du dir vorstellst
Aber macht keiner
Also ich habe im Vorstellungsgespräch
Gesagt auf die Frage
Was ist ihre Gehaltsvorstellung 115k
Und da haben die dann natürlich
Gemacht
So wie das immer gemacht wird
Ja
Und dann haben sie mir
Und das war eigentlich eine ganz gute Verhandlungstaktik
Von denen falls es eine Taktik war
Dann haben sie mir vorgerechnet
Moment die Musik ist ein bisschen
Laut heute
Dann haben sie gesagt sie können so viel nicht
Bezahlen das wird nicht ins Gehaltsgefüge passen
Oder irgendwie sowas in der Richtung
Und da habe ich schon gedacht
Okay okay jetzt kommt die Nummer wieder
Und auf einmal fangen sie mir an
Vorzurechnen dass ich ja aber
Im Prinzip
Doch
Auf diesen Betrag komme
Wenn der Bonus halbwegs stimmt
Und auch nicht mal mit dem maximalsten
Bonus
Also schon mit dem
Durchschnittsbonus und
Da habe ich gesagt ja okay
Auf geht's let's go
Also im Prinzip haben sie gesagt sie können so
Einen Vertrag schreiben aber unterm Strich
Gibt's das
Und da habe ich gesagt okay auf geht's
Aber was ist halt unverschämt
Unverschämt ist der Moment
Wo du
In deinem Bauch merkst dass es cringet
Wenn du das
Du musst dir vorstellen
Du antwortest und ab dem Moment
Wo du selbst es kaum
Noch ertragen kannst den Betrag zu
Sagen das ist dann kurz vor unverschämt
Nice
Hast du jetzt erst angefangen
Oder
Bist du schon
Also man liest sich so als
Hat sie jetzt erst angefangen
Weil die meisten Ausbildungen gehen ja eigentlich
Erst so August September los
Oder fängst du quasi im August
An
Im Osten ist es einfach billiger zu leben denke ich mir
Deswegen
Kommen die Leute da mit weniger Geld aus
Da kann
Die Firma vielleicht noch mehr Stonks machen
Wenn die international
Deutschlandweit ihr Kram verkauft
Ja ne ich auch
Ich hab heute übrigens was recht cooles gesehen
In der Werbung
Wie hieß
Das da
Weiß ich ob das jemand von euch
Schon mal ausprobiert hat
Hab ich heute eine Werbung gesehen
Ich fand das eigentlich gar nicht schlecht
Und zwar
Die Seite sieht kacke aus
Die sieht richtig mies aus mit Darkreader
Wenn ich das richtig
Verstanden hab dann kannst du dir
Verschiedene Boxen kaufen
Einmal in der Woche alle 2 Wochen alle 3 Wochen
Und die verkaufen quasi
Obst und Gemüse
Günstiger was sonst weggeschmissen
Wurden wäre weil es nicht die richtige
Form hat
Also quasi wenn
Keine Ahnung hier
Wenn die Radieschen nicht der EU Norm
Entsprechen
Weggeschmissen werden normalerweise
Dann kaufen die die und bieten das günstige an
Ich fand die Idee dahinter ehrlich gesagt gar nicht so schlecht
Da kriegste
Da kriegste irgendwie
Starterbox 19 Euro
Da kriegste irgendwie 3 Kilo
3 Kilo Zeug
Für 3 Kilo
Bio Obst und Gemüse für 20 Euro
Ich hab keine Ahnung ob das preislich
Überhaupt sinnvoll ist
Ich hab mich jetzt einfach mal davon
Einwickeln lassen in der Werbung
Ob es das wirklich ist weiß ich gar nicht
Ich fand die Idee aber gar nicht schlecht
Also Leute
Wenn einer von euch zuguckt hier
Ich lass mich gerne sponsern
Und probier das aus
Und mach dann auf Twitch
Ein
Unboxing und live eating
Oder
Wenn ihr Budget habt dann auch auf Youtube
Fast 300k
Subscribers
Live eating dann mit
ASMR Eating Stream
Das machen wir nicht
Ich finde das
Übelst abartig
Also ich gucke ja ganz gerne mal
Das ein oder andere ASMR Video
Aber diese
Eating Sounds Videos das halte ich nicht aus
Das finde ich immer richtig eklig
Wenn die dir dann ins Ohr schmatzen
Was ich auch mega eklig finde
Kennt ihr diese
Koreanischen
Zusammen-Ess-Videos
Wisst ihr was ich mein
Ich find die Dinger mega abartig
Es gibt so
Videos das kommt aus dem asiatischen Raum
Und die fressen
Immer richtig viel auf einmal
So irgendwie
So nach dem Motto
Ja ein kleiner
Snack
Ich hab jetzt erstmal hier so
Ein halbes Rind bei mir
Drei Hähnchen als Chicken Wings
Oder irgendwie
Ich mach jetzt mal kurz Korean BBQ hier
Hab ich bestellt mal so eine ganze Platte
Das ist immer eine riesen Menge
Und das stopfen die dann
In sich rein und boah
Die essen das nicht einfach nur
Die stopfen sich wirklich
Alle backen voll
Und die Leute stehen da
Voll drauf auf den Essens-Sound
Ich find das so eklig alter
Ich kann mir das nicht angucken
Aber ich hab eh so
Ich werd eh übelst getriggert
Durch Essensgeräusche
Ich hatte mal
Ich glaube
Ich glaube ich weiß sogar woran das liegt
Warum ich es eklig finde
Wenn Leute irgendwo im Gesicht
Essen hängen haben oder sowas
Also auch wenn es so ein
Kleiner Fleck Joghurt ist
Ich find das mega eklig und ich glaube ich weiß woher das
Woran das liegt dass so ein kleines
Kindheitstrauma was ich hab
Ich weiß noch ich war mal
Doch Kindheitstrauma kann man
Bei einem Kumpel damals
Aus der Schule
Daheim am Wochenende übernachten
Und der hatte eine kleine Schwester
Und beim Abendessen
Die kleine Schwester war damals keine Ahnung
Wir waren wahrscheinlich so acht neun
Die kleine Schwester war keine Ahnung drei
Vier und die kleine Schwester
Von dem die hat Spinat
Gefuttert und die hat sich den Spinat
In die Nase geschoben und in die Ohren
Geschoben und ich wusste
Echt als ich das gesehen habe
Wusste ich damals schon halb kotzen
Weil ich das so eklig fand und ich glaube
Deswegen habe ich Probleme
Wenn Leute beim Essen irgendwas im Gesicht
Hängen haben
Richtig abartig
Allein schon wenn ich dran denke
Finde ich das immer noch
Leute ihr könnt euch überlegen
Als ich acht war
Könnt ihr euch überlegen das ist 30 Jahre her
Einfach
Und das finde ich immer noch abartig
Das Bild habe ich immer noch im Kopf
Also ich hätte auch fast
Einen Vertrag unterschrieben
Bei einem Unternehmen aus Würzburg
Und ihr wisst
Das ist von mir jetzt auch schon ein bisschen weg
So eineinhalb bis zwei Stunden
Bist du da unterwegs
Bis du da bist
Also du bist zwei Stunden unterwegs bis du da bist
Als von mir wenn es los geht zwei Stunden
Bis ich dort bin
Also es ist auf jeden Fall ein ordentlicher Weg
Und
Mit denen habe ich ausgemacht
Ich muss nur einmal im Monat vor Ort sein
Das wäre okay gewesen
Da wäre ich einmal hingefahren zu irgendeinem
Teammeeting
Aber es hat sich ja glücklicherweise sogar noch anders ergeben
Ich glaube ich habe jetzt auch die Stelle
Die besser passt bei mir
Und ich muss echt mal sagen
Also es war im Nachhinein betrachtet
Ich wusste es ja nicht
Es war so ein bisschen kaltes Wasser
Ich wusste ja nicht ob das wirklich so toll ist
Wie man es sich erzählt
Aber ich muss echt sagen
So jetzt bin ich dreieinhalb Monate
Dort bei der neuen Arbeit
Das war schon die richtige Entscheidung
Die haben eine super Arbeitsatmosphäre
Auch teamübergreifend und in Projekten
Super Homeoffice Regelung und die Kohle stimmt auch noch
Und ich kann weiterhin Montags
80% Teilzeit arbeiten
Also Montags nicht arbeiten
Also ganz ehrlich
Die Kombination ist einfach top
Und die Aussicht auf mehr Kohle ist auch da
Auch da
Über unterschiedlichste Wege
Und regelmäßige
Zieldefinierungen und Rücksprachen
Und hast du nicht gemacht
Also es ist nicht schlecht
Ich glaube ich gebe mir dort auch mehr Mühe
Als ich mir die letzten Jahre beim alten Arbeitgeber
Überhaupt gegeben habe
Einfach weil es
Irgendwo so noch Bock macht
Ne das machen wir heute nicht
Um sich vor der Unterhaltszahlung zu drücken
Meinst du?
Ich meine man weiß ja nie
Was der Chat für Probleme hat und warum sowas gefragt wird
Kann ja alles mögliche sein
Aber ganz ehrlich
Ich finde vor der Unterhaltszahlung
Sollte man sich nicht drücken
Ich spreche da aus Erfahrung
Mein Vater hat auch keinen Unterhalt bezahlt
Und hat sich rausgeredet mit Zeug
Meine Mutter wollte ihn natürlich
Damals aufgrund des
Wie soll man sagen so hier
Friedens quasi nicht verklagen
Die Aussage von meinem Vater
Zu meiner Mutter damals muss gewesen sein
Jetzt haltet euch mal fest
Zu der Zeit hat er noch richtig dick Stonks gemacht
Hab ich euch ja erzählt
Dass mein Vater ein bisschen die Leute gescamt hat
Und damit übelst viel Geld gemacht hat
Ähm
Der muss zu meiner Mutter damals gesagt haben
Also ich brauche erstmal
10.000 im Monat für mich
Danach kann ich euch was geben
Ihr müsst euch überlegen
Das war ja
Anfang der 90er
10.000 Euro im Monat
Vor 30 Jahren
Das war extrem viel Geld
Ich mein das ist jetzt noch viel Geld
Aber das war damals noch mal extremst viel mehr Geld
Musst ihr mal vorstellen
Ja
Ich brauche erstmal 10.000 Euro für mich
Danach kann ich euch vielleicht was geben
Was ne Aussage alter
Nicht Euro Mark
Plötzlich
Euro kann das nicht gewesen sein
Hehe
Nee
Er hat gesagt ich brauche erstmal 10.000 im Monat für mich
Muss er sich mal vorstellen
Also
Ich vermute mal das war so
Also ich bin 1984 geboren das dürfte so
Dann rum gewesen sein
Und da waren 10.000 Mark echt noch richtig krass viel Geld
Im Monat
Das war mehr damals als heute 10.000 Euro im Monat
Ja
Also
Er hat gesagt
Dass er sich nicht irgendwie vom Acker gemacht hat oder so
Sondern
Meine Mutter hat ihn rausgeschmissen
Weil er fremd gegangen ist
Auf irgendeiner Geschäftsreise
Also der hat es eigentlich doppelt verkackt
Und
Dann wollte er noch nicht mal was bezahlen
Das muss man sich echt mal vorstellen
Also wie gesagt
Leute lange Rede kurzer Sinn
Drückt euch nicht davor
Was soll da scheiß
Wir müssen auch irgendwie über die Runden kommen
Hast du deine Weisheitsszene noch
Nee
Moin
Ich muss mal kurz den Chat
Dann gehen wir auch gleich zu Amazon
Weil wir haben nur noch eine Stunde Zeit
Ich würde immer mehr sagen als mit dem was man zufrieden ist
Immer
Und es ist egal
Also ja sie werden immer versuchen
Wenn möglich das ein bisschen runter zu drücken
Und auf der anderen Seite
Wenn es über ihrer Schmerzgrenze ist
Dann werden die das schon sagen
Die schicken dich nicht heim
Nur weil du sagst du willst zu viel Geld haben
Die sagen nicht
Die sagen ja okay
Müssen wir irgendwie gucken
Die versuchen das schon dann so hinzubekommen
Die werden dir nicht gleich sagen
Unsere Schmerzgrenze liegt da und da
Nee ich würde immer mehr sagen
Ich würde grundsätzlich immer mehr sagen
Als das mit dem ich zufrieden bin
Ich meine du kannst ja im Prinzip nichts
Verlieren dadurch
Du kannst dadurch nichts verlieren
Also entweder sagen die
Jawoll easy machen wir
Obwohl du schon viel mehr gesagt hast
Dann könntest du höchstens noch ein bisschen sauer auf dich sein
Du hättest noch mehr sagen sollen
Ähm
Oder
Sie sagen passt nicht
Und dann nähert ihr euch irgendwie ein bisschen an
Oder aber
Es ist so weit unter dem was du dir vorstellen willst
Dann halt nicht
Also im Endeffekt
Ist es immer gut
Du sagst mehr
Und wie gesagt ich würde auch
Ordentlich mehr
Also ordentlich was sagen
Gleich am Anfang
Ich hab's eigentlich verkehrt gemacht
Ich hätte noch mehr sagen sollen
Ich hab nämlich auch was
Realistisches gesagt
Und wer weiß
Hätte ich einfach nochmal 20k drauf gehauen
Vielleicht hätte es dann unter dem Strich auch mehr gegeben
Aber ich will mich jetzt mal nicht beschweren
Das ist immer noch ziemlich nice
Aha
In August geht's los
GLHF
Best Practice
Du meinst wie du beim Desktop Start deine Programme startest
Ähm
Ich mach das so
Ich weiß aber nicht ob das Best Practice ist
Das ist wahrscheinlich so
Komplett Anti Best Practice
Keine Ahnung
Ich mach das in meinen Start Script
Du sagst ja Start X
Am Anfang
Immer für die grafische Session zum starten
Und Start X führt die X in den RC aus
So und was ich da mache
Ist im Hintergrund die Programme starten
Und am Ende i3 starten
Ob das wirklich so sinnvoll ist
Keine Ahnung aber das mach ich schon immer so
War schon ewig so
Ja gut Wayland User keine Ahnung
Du brauchst keinen Login Manager
Hier sieht das aus als hätte ich einen Login Manager
Ich sag Start X
Auf der Kommandozelle
Man kann mit i3 exakt Programme starten
Ich weiß
Mach ich aber nicht
Schreib das in meinen Start Script rein
Hast du viele Meetings auf deiner Arbeit
Oh ja ziemlich viele
Übertrieben viele an manchen Tagen
Nächste Woche Dienstag ist wieder von morgens bis abends
Gemiete
Ja so sieht's aus
Machst du grad die Ausbildung
Oder bist du schon fertig
Ich glaube nicht
Dass wir offiziell nach ITIL arbeiten
Es wird mal in manchen
Dokumenten so
Rumrum geschmissen
Was von Prozessen und ITIL
Und so
Genau streng genommen nach ITIL arbeitet eh niemand
Und das sagt glaube ich
Sagen auch die ganzen ITIL Guidelines da
Dass man sich das rauspicken soll
Was gut zum jeweiligen Unternehmen passt
Es schreiben gerne viele rein
Erfahrung mit
ITIL
Safe
Scrum
Agile
Irgendwas und was es da noch alles gibt
Aber letztendlich
Ist immer Auslegungssache
So lass uns mal schnell nochmal
Nach SSDs gucken
Das ist das was ich eigentlich machen will
Was würdest du sagen ist ein angemessenes Gehalt
Für 3 Jahre Ausbildung plus 4 Jahre Berufserfahrung
Das ist doch schon mal ordentlich ja
3 Jahre Ausbildung
Also 4 Jahre Berufserfahrung
Techsec.net
Sehr gute Wahl
Neue Technologien und etwas Erfahrung in Frontend
Node, React, TypeScript
Hast du ein GitHub Projekt?
Oder hast du ein GitHub Account?
Den würde ich auf jeden Fall immer mitschicken
Ja man kann das so pauschal immer nicht sagen
Es kommt auf die Stelle an auf die man sich bewirbt
Es kommt auf die Branche an
Es kommt auf die Region an
Es kommt darauf an
Wie genau suchen das kann man so pauschal nicht sagen
Ja dann wird es
Zeit für ein Public GitHub Account
Also gerade wenn du dich
Als Programmierer bewirbst ist das
Ist das sehr nice
Ich persönlich kann es dir nicht sagen
Wie die Personalabteilungen in Deutschland
Im Durchschnitt ticken
Denk dir was aus
Ich kann dir nicht sagen wie die Personalabteilungen
In Deutschland so im Durchschnitt ticken
Ob die meisten in GitHub Accounts reingucken oder nicht
Aber ich gehe davon aus dass die
Etwas moderneren Unternehmen
Es durchaus nice finden
Wenn du ein GitHub Account angegeben hast
Und die gucken da auch rein
Sogar bei mir
Und ich bin kein hauptberuflicher Entwickler
Haben sie in den GitHub Account reingeguckt
Und wir haben im Vorstellungsgespräch
Über GitHub
Eines der GitHub Projekte kurz geredet
Ja Personalabteilungen
Nehmen es ja zur Kenntnis wenn sowas drinnen steht
Also Personalabteilung filtert das ja auch
Vorher schon alles ein bisschen
Und dann ist halt die Frage ob das bei denen quasi ein Kriterium ist
Aha hat ein GitHub Account oder nicht
Lass uns mal kurz den Storage angucken
Das interessiert mich
Ich brauche nämlich tatsächlich noch 1-2 USB Sticks
Ein bisschen größere
Was haben wir denn hier sonst so
Prime Day
Okay das ist einfach nur
Ich check Amazon wieder nicht
Was ist das jetzt für ein Müll
Top 100 Angebote
Was sind denn die Top 100
Ein Pfannenset 11 teilig
Das habe ich gebraucht
Oder für 1400
Den neuen Roborock S8
Pro Ultra
Den ich noch nicht mal flashen kann
Und mit Custom Firmware unten
Wo ich die China Chinesen App und Zeug verwenden muss
Wo würdest du bei deinem GitHub
In deiner Bewerbung schicken
Also in den schreiben
Im Lebenslauf habe ich das stehen gehabt
Also ich habe in meinem Lebenslauf stehen gehabt
Unten drunter
Also ich habe hier berufliche Erfahrung
Blablabla
Und unten habe ich noch
Weiteres
Dazu geschrieben
Da habe ich unter anderem reingeschrieben
Mehrere Open Source Projekte auf GitHub
Zum Beispiel für Elektroautos
Blablabla GitHub
Dann habe ich noch reingeschrieben
Seit 2012
Nebenberuflich
Web Videoproduzent
So nennt man das übrigens offiziell
Das heißt nicht Content Creator oder Influencer
Oder was auch immer
Es heißt Web Videoproduzent in Deutschland
Gibt es auch noch was witziges zu
Letztens hat mich so eine Frau vom Zensus angerufen
Hattet ihr auch schon mal die Ehre
Den Zensus machen zu müssen
Pains Champ
Ich muss den jetzt schon zum dritten Mal machen
Den Zensus
Da ruft dich so eine an
Und stellt dir Fragen
Beziehungsweise
Termin ausmachen
Und sie stellt dir Fragen
Und da ging es dann auch so
Ich habe ihr gesagt ich arbeite Teilzeit
Ich mache nebenberuflich noch was anderes
Ja was machen sie denn nebenberuflich
Und da habe ich gesagt
Web Videoproduzent
Und dann hat sie in ihrer Dropdown Liste gesucht
Ob das da drinne steht
Und es stand da nicht drinne
Und da wusste sie nicht was sie auswählen soll
Blabla
So aktuell sind diese
Listen da noch nicht
Wollen wir mal eine Umfrage machen
Ja
Wir können die
Wir können die große Wubblers Gehaltsumfrage machen
Nicht heute
Aber erinnere mich mal dran
Das machen wir im nächsten oder in einem der nächsten Streams dann
Schlagt es das nächste Mal noch mal vor
Im nächsten Stream machen wir es dann
Wir machen den großen
Wubblers Gehaltscheck
Das bringt glaube ich schon was
Da muss ich aber ein bisschen mehr
Da müsste man eigentlich eine Umfrage machen
Die nicht auf Twitch geht
Wir müssten beispielsweise mehrere Sachen fragen
Wir müssten abfragen
Die Branche, die Region vielleicht
Und
Die
Die Jobbezeichnung
Sowas
Wir können auch einfach
Wir können auch mal
Genau Erfahrungen und sowas
Hochgerechnet auf 5 Tage würde ich immer
Immer
Ja das können wir echt
Das war mal einfach eine Umfrage
Ok lasst mal kurz gucken was haben wir denn
Haben wir noch gescheite andere Kategorien
Prime Day endet bald
Ja ich weiß
Lul
Ok also was haben wir denn hier
Schönes zu bieten
4 Terabyte für 189
Oh das ist nice
Ach die da
Die sind nicht so geil
Also gestern habe ich glaube
Lasst mal gucken
Was habe ich denn gestern sinnlos ausgegeben
Lasst mal kurz zusammenrechnen
Ich habe übrigens Offstream noch was anderes gekauft
Also
Was haben wir denn ausgegeben
16,30 Euro
Also jetzt rechnen wir das mal zusammen
50 Euro
120 Euro
170 Euro
180 Euro habe ich gestern ausgegeben
Das geht doch eigentlich noch
Ich hätte jetzt gedacht es war mehr
Empfehle mal eine gute
1 bis 2 Terabyte
M2 SSD
Ganz einfach kann ich dir empfehlen
Guck mal
Du gehst mal hier hin
Und dann
Auf eines meiner Videos
Und dann mein PC
Sein Geiz halt Reffling
Dann verdiene ich nämlich auch ein bisschen was
Und dann guckst du dir mal an
Was ich für eine SSD drin habe
Stellst du fest das ist eine Samsung
990 pro 2 Terabyte
Das ist eines der besten SSDs die du dir holen kannst
Hatte ich nicht Probleme mit der Firmware
Weiß ich nicht
Vielleicht
War das Clickbait oder ist Battlepit
In deinen Augen wirklich Overhyped
Da musst du das Video gucken
Ich brauche Viewtime
Ältere Firmware
Hatte extreme
Degradation
Wie kann man
Seine SSDs checken
Hat Windows ein Tool dabei
Wie man seine SSD
Wir Leveling
Checken kann
Mit was für einem Tool
Macht man das
So geht das wahrscheinlich nicht oder
Wie heißt das Ding
Samsung Magician
It's not magic
It's software
Ist das der SSD Gandalf
Aha so sieht das dann aus
Ok Download
Das Ding hier muss man sich installieren
Der Samsung
SSD
Integrated Software Installer
Ich dachte das ist der
Samsung Magician
Den man hier
Moment ich hab das falsche
Ich hab das falsche runtergeladen
For Consumer SSDs
Samsung Magician
Installer
Ok
Ich installiere das jetzt einfach mal
Dann gucken wir was das
Wir Leveling meiner SSD macht
Wow
Ok
Select Language
Englisch
Und jetzt
Ah ne
Next
I accept
Äh ich accepte alles
Desktop meinetwegen
Install
Ok Samsung dann verzaubert mich mal
Sagt mir ob meine SSD
Kaputt ist oder nicht oder kaputt geht
Wait
Help Window
Ok was
Was sieht man da so
Moment
Ist das Fullscreen
Ne Fuck
Kann man das Fullscreen irgendwie
Ne das geht nicht Fullscreen
Das ist Hardcoded immer
Eine Größe
Ok
Not Available
Hier
Die Pro
Warum geht das
Drive Health nicht
Weil Magic
Und Drive Details
Smart
Available Spare
Available Threshold
Percentage Used
Update
Firmware Updates
Ne es gibt gar keine Firmware Updates für meine SSD
Latest Firmware
Aber Moment
Warum
Warum erkennt er dann das hier nicht
Weil es die Systemplatte ist
Vielleicht
Ne
Na geil
Excellent Samsung
Können die das nicht
Samsung Magician Software
Ne guck
Die wird unterstützt
Moment es stand beim
Da steht doch unterstützte SSDs
Muss
Wie beim Download stand das es nicht unterstützt wird
Da steht doch
990 Pro Series
Steht doch da das es funktioniert
Ich glaube ich müsste jetzt Rebooten
Rebooten dann geht es wahrscheinlich
Da ist nichts raus geworden
Das gebatet ganz schön
Weil das dann immer nach vorne springt
Samsung
Magician
Does not detect
Jawoll genau das Problem
Hab ich auch
Moment der sieht ja wenigstens was hier
Ich will das jetzt eigentlich nicht debunken
Warum das Scheiß nicht funktioniert
Ja es ist bestimmt
Scam
Ist klar
Ich bin aber nicht der einzige der das Problem hat
Wo findet man
Was kann man sonst noch ausprobieren
Leute
Wie ist das andere Ding
Crystal Disk
Crystal Disk Info
Ist das die richtige Seite oder ist das
Scammers
Wait a minute wo bin ich denn hier gelandet
Was ist das
Crystal Disk Info
Ja Zip ist ok
Ich kann es auch einfach von Heise runterladen
Da weiß ich wenigstens dass ich kein Scam runterlade
Aber da gibt es das nur als
Dachkomm
Nimm den Ayayaskin
Also dass die Samsung Software halt nicht
Funktioniert ist schon merkwürdig
So ich mach mal kurz
Einen neuen Ordner
Ich lösch das ja danach auch wieder
Ich will jetzt einfach nur mal gucken was das
Releveling von meiner SSD
Geologist das können wir gleich machen
Was brauchen wir
Disk Info 64
Ok das muss man alles gut ausführen alles klar
Was zum Teufel ist das für eine Sprache
Die ich darunter geladen hab
What the fuck
Polnisch
Kann jemand
Tschechisch oder Polnisch und weiß
Wie man die Sprache umstellt
Warum ist das
Polnisch alter
Language
Englisch ja wunderbar
Ok sehr schön
Und wo sieht man jetzt das Relevel
Healthstatus 94
94 ist aber ganz schön
Schlecht oder
Für das dass es erst
Dass ich das erst
Vor einem halben Jahr gekauft hab
Was sagen
Meine anderen
Die KUVO
Sagt 98
Die sagt 100%
Die EVO sagt noch 100%
Die hatte ich viel länger
Vielleicht soll ich doch mal
Firmware updaten
Wo sieht man denn die Firmware
Hier Firmware
3er Firmware ist auf jeden Fall betroffen
Hier sieht man noch
Total host
Rights
Ja das ist ja nix
Guck mal
25TB
Sehe ich das richtig
Hab ich 25TB geschrieben
Nach 25TB Rights
Sollte die nicht noch auf
94% runter sein
Ah ok ok
Das heißt
Ok
Aber warum der Samsung Magician
Das check ich nicht
Das juckt ja nicht
Der erkennt das einfach nicht
Der erkennt die Firmware
Und alles ja schön aber
Insufficient Space
Er checkt das mit dem Update nicht
Ok
Da muss ich auf jeden Fall Firmware updaten Leute
Gut dass wir drüber
gesprochen haben
Links unten Update
Chat wisst ihr wovon ihr schreibt
Oder schreibt ihr einfach nur
Ich vermute nämlich die manche Leute
Schreiben einfach nur
Weil da steht es natürlich nicht drin
Mach einfach Update
Ja aber da gibt es kein Update hier drüber
Warum erkennt der
Magician das nicht
Das ist komisch
Wie macht man denn ein Update
Pro
Firmware
Hier
Handbücher und Downloads
Data Migration Tool
Magician Software 7.2
Was haben wir denn hier für eine
Magician Software
Wo sieht man die Version von diesem Ding
7.3
Haben wir sogar
Und das ist guck mal
7.3 Leute pass mal auf
Wahrscheinlich ist 7.3
Verbuggt für meine SSD
Äh
Samsung
Magician wir uninstallen den
Installieren die Version
Die offiziell aus Samsung für dieser
Yes
Download
Samsung Magician braucht
Ein Reboot
Was ist das
Egal ich mach das nachher
Das ist noch eine ältere Version
7.0
Magician Software
Warum gibt es das zweimal
Hehehe
Ok Chat
Ne Iso
Ne
Wollen die mich veräppeln
Ne Iso
Ne
Ich krieg das bestimmt
In den Magician laufen
Und zur Not starte ich das Ding mal neu
Funktioniert so ein Update
Samsung SSD
Firmware Update
Da passiert wahrscheinlich nichts mit den Daten
Die drauf sind oder
Ich hab jetzt kein Bock ein Vollbackup zu machen
Eigentlich nicht
Ja
Äh das guck mal
Ja also das ist tatsächlich
Für 25 Terabyte
Viel zu viel
An
Ja
Was ist das beste Angebot
Also ich denke
Die Steckdosen die wir gestern
Bestellt haben unter der Voraussetzung
Dass das alles so funktioniert
Wie gedacht das weiß ich aber noch nicht
Das müssen wir uns im Stream angucken
Welche
Ok ich trau mich nicht zu suchen
But Milf
Moment wo hab ich das
Milf
Milfra
ich traue mich kaum das wort einzugeben in die suche hier aber
Die haben wir gestern bestellt die sind nicht mehr verfügbar die gab es mit coupon für 9 euro 9 euro 99
für vier steckdosen
die angeblich
Flashbar sind mit custom firmware
Und sogar schaltbaren also remote schaltbaren usb haben also das ist das ist echt nicht verkehrt
Hast du etwa den browser verlauflich geklärt nee habe ich nicht aber ich habe ja auch nicht schlimmes gesucht hier drin
Weil es ein extra rechner für streaming ist hier lockt das ist was anderes
Ja genau
Das hoffe ich ja auch ich hoffe dass das esp chip sind noch also laut
Laut amazon
Bewertung haben leute das motor drauf geflasht aber ich weiß halt nicht ob das noch funktioniert
Ich persönlich glaube ja nicht dass sie noch mit tuya convert gehen tuya convert ist die ota geschichte
dass also viele der neuen hardware
Wird da ja nicht mehr supportet weil die neuere versionen haben oder gar kein esp
schon mal über ein kühlschrank update nachgedacht ich habe meinen kühlschrank erst letztens gefixt
Ich habe letztens an meinen kühlschrank erst neuen griff dran gemacht weil der alte abgebrochen ist
habe ich habe ich bestellt bei amazon für 15 euro china chinesen griff
Funktioniert genauso gut wie der originale griff so eigentlich haben wir nicht wirklich viel viel gemacht der sinnvoll ist
Wir haben eine ssd meine ssd die backt
Smart kühlschrank mit display finde ich komplett sinnlos braucht keiner
das immer kurz gucken
werkzeuge sind immer nice und dann gucken wir
Okay was ist im trend was kaufen die leute bei amazon im trend
Okay absoluter shit weil keiner braucht
und dann gucken wir noch mal schnell durch was die
computer und software
ihr
Speicherprodukte genau da wollen wir mal kurz durchgucken also was was haben wir denn was haben wir denn jetzt hier zu bieten unter
Baumarkt ist da irgendwas spannendes drin weil hier ist ja werkzeug kann man nie zu viel haben
Echt aber wie bekommst du wie bekommst du die software denn dann drauf dann brauchst du ja trotzdem erstmal die china chinesen die china chinesen
Um es initial einzurichten einmal weil du kriegst die dinge ja nicht zurück geflasht auf die alte version
so
Lacht mich da irgendwas an was ich haben will
dremel
Aber also ich habe ich habe ja ein und er ist wirklich sehr sehr praktisch
Also sowas in der richtung hier habe ich und er ist wirklich sehr sehr praktisch
Aber ich brauche ihn sehr selten
Also wenn ich ihn brauche ist er mega praktisch aber ich brauche ihn nicht oft
So und so ein teil in der richtung habe ich ja ich bin mir nicht ganz sicher welchen ich gekauft habe damals kurz gucken
3000 das aller das aller kleinste was es gab
Habe ich damals gekauft hier das teil ja aber preisleistung ist tatsächlich ganz gut weil ich brauche den so selten
Ist das eine mini flex?
Du kannst sie du kannst ihn als mini flex verwenden
Also ich habe damit
Mal
Ein wäscheständer durchgeschnitten das metall das metall vom wäscheständer
Wäscheständer
Mehrere wäscheständer durchgeschnitten fragt es nicht warum ich wäscheständer durchschneiden
Ja mit mit so einer mit so einer trennscheibe nennt sich das ja glaube ich
Und da ist mir zum ersten mal aufgefallen dass wenn man metall mit metall
Durchschneidet dass dann funken sprühen
Man hätte das eigentlich wissen können
Aber irgendwie habe ich mir da vor feld keine gedanken drüber gemacht
Und da war es doch ganz gut dass ich dass ich so eine schutzbrille hier habe
Nein ich habe ich habe nicht dem nachbarn und den nachbarn den wäscheständer durchgeschnitten ich habe meinen wäscheständer durchgeschnitten
mehrere wäscheständer habe ich durchgeschnitten ich glaube
glaube zwei stück waren es
Jetzt bin jetzt
Es waren entweder zwei oder vier
Also okay ich erkläre euch warum ich wäscheständer durchgeschnitten habe ich habe ich habe mir ich denn jetzt waren vier das waren vier
Ich habe mir vier ganz billige wäscheständer gekauft
Gab es mir über all dem angebot oder so ganz billiges zeug irgendwie sechs euro pro wäscheständer oder sowas die haben auch keine farbe das
Ist einfach nur metall und und wirklich billig
und von dem wäscheständer habe ich die
Beine abgeschnitten und hat dann habe ich nur noch okay moment
Oben auf wäscheständer
metal
Ja sowas sowas ganz billiges habe ich hier so hier oben guckt man
Hier oben hat man doch so einen so einen metall rahmen mit so steben
Was ich gemacht habe ist ich habe die beine abgeschnitten und ich habe hier oben diese auslege ab und diese diese
Aufhänglinge ab und ich habe dann das dann war es doch nur zwei dann war es doch nur zwei
und ich habe das ding benutzt
Und noch ein anderes nebendran
Und daraus habe ich eine tür gebaut
Weil das genau von den abständen gepasst hat ja guckt nicht
also keine tür
also
der türteil von der tür
Die genau komplett nebeneinander und das kannst du die zwei seiten aufmachen
Ja
Tür
Und okay also
Ich vielleicht mache ich euch da mal ein bild von ich kann euch sagen wofür es ist und zwar
Das haus das hat ja einen hof und das hat einen garten und das hat eine terrasse
Garten und das hat eine terrasse
So und meine katze
Ist eigentlich eine reine hauskatze gewesen für tschickos bude du hast richtig erkannt für die katze habe ich das gebaut richtig
So und meine katze ist eigentlich eine reine hauskatze immer gewesen
Also haben die auch beim tierheim gesagt und irgendwann habe ich mir gedacht alter die katze kommt da nicht durch
Kommt nicht durch
Jetzt ist sie nicht exakt so ein ding aber passt passt schon so und
Was ich gemacht habe ist ich habe mir gedacht die freut sich bestimmt mega wenn sie raus kann
Und dann habe ich sie ein paar mal auf die terrasse gelassen
Und das fand die toll die rollt sich dann immer draußen rum und liegt in der sonne und das finde ich ganz super
So und jetzt muss ich mir überlegen wie schaffe ich es die terrasse so abzusichern
dass die katze
Da nicht rauskommt mein hof ist zwar auch halbwegs katzen sicher so zum größten teil aber tschicko bei tschicko weiß man nie
Und was ich gemacht habe ist
Ich habe ein drahtseil genommen
Und habe das von der hauswand zur stallwand rüber gespannt
Dadurch dann habe ich mir so einen sonnen extra wieder
Widerstandsfestes netz gekauft
Bei so einem shop der sich spezialisiert hat auf so katzen
Netze für außenanlagen und sowas dann habe ich das netz über das stahlseil drüber drüber gemacht und das heißt das ist jetzt quasi
die vordere beschränkung zwischen stahl und dem haus an der terrasse
ist
Ist halt jetzt so einen so einen zaun im katzennetz
Und
Ja damit man da gescheit wenn die katze draußen ist dran vorbeikommt habe ich auch so zwei
Oberteilen von einem wäscheständer habe ich so eine minitür gebaut
Dass wenn man da rausgeht
Beziehungsweise wenn die katze da irgendwie an der stelle wo man runter geht von der terrasse dann den hof
Irgendwie mal durch schlüpft dass sie dann halt hier davor steht und das klappt
Das klappt ich lasse die mittlerweile stundenlang alleine draußen und die liegen die rollt sich darum
Wenn die rein will komme ich das mit
Und die kann theoretisch auch durch die klappe rein
und
Die macht keine anstalten auszubrechen
Ja, und das habe ich mal mit meinem dremel gemacht
Also wäscheständer durchgeschnitten zum beispiel ich habe noch mehr sachen damit gemacht also wie gesagt nicht oft
Aber wenn man es braucht sind die dinger mega praktisch ich habe auch mal irgendwelche sachen poliert damit
Ich habe den
die tür vom schrank gefixt damit
Da will ich euch auch nicht erzählen wie ja der
Also die tür vom schrank das ist so ganz billiges ikea
Ja, genau das teil ist das
Schauen wir mal schauen wir mal bin mal gespannt ob es funktioniert
Wenn nicht mache ich auf
und löte das dran an die
An die kontakte aber wenn dann kein esp mehr drin ist habe ich verloren aber 9 euro ich mein scheiß drauf
Da zumindest der schrank hat so eine presssparen tür
Ja korrekt du hast durchschaut
Also folgender folgender vorfall
Fenster ist offen
katze
liegt versteckt
halb unterm bett
Ich krabbel da runter will mal gucken was die so macht
Und ich renne mir beim aufstehen den kopf am am offenen also an der
An dem feld an dem offenen fenster an also an dem rahmen vom offenen fenster
Und habe ich halt gesagt scheiße und habe gegen den schrank geboxt
Und dann hat der schrank so eine delle gehabt weil das einfach nur so presse presssparen
platte war
Und das und das habe ich auch zum teil zumindest mit dem dremel gefixt
also ein bisschen aufgeraut
Für für zum zum zuschmieren und so aber es hat nicht so ganz gut funktioniert danach da kann der dremel aber nichts für
Und dann habe ich einfach einen aufkleber drüber gepackt
Nee nee ich wollte ich wollte das eigentlich auffüllen also mein ursprünglicher plan war
Ich rau das ein bisschen an so alles da drunter
Dann fülle ich da so eine so eine auffüllmasse rein
Und und macht dann farbe drüber
Aber das hatten als bis zum farbe drüber machen bin ich gar nicht gekommen ich war zu blöd das mit dem auffüllen da
Irgendwie eben zu kriegen und dann habe ich es einfach so gelassen
und hat einen aufkleber drüber gepackt sondern
gut
Spezialisierung auf legacy in der it kobold nee
Es sei denn du stehst auf legacy sachen wie alt ist die katze
Top 12
So 100 prozentig weiß man sie nicht aber die ist auf jeden fall schon älter
Aber ich hatte nur alte katzen hier bisher
Die sind auch immer super entspannt alte katzen und du und du weißt was du kriegst ja
Die ändern sich nicht von heute auf morgen
Wenn du dich mit der von aber am anfang verstehst verstehst du dich später mit der auch
Wann machst du ein katzen tierheim auf?
ohne scheiß
Wenn ich ich würde ich würde also wenn ich wirklich
Übelst viel geld machen würde mit irgendwas
Dann würde ich dann würde ich irgendwas in der richtung machen ich würde vielleicht kein katzen tierheim eröffnen oder sowas aber ich würde irgendwas
in der richtung machen
weil ich ehrlich gesagt
Ja also ehrlich gesagt muss ich sagen
Das ist das einzige was mich allgemein nützlich so interessiert
Ich rede von richtig von richtig viel kohle wenn ich richtig viel kohle hätte wenn ich jetzt irgendwie keine ahnung
Testweise ein webservice baue und dann kommt
Der zug um die ecke und sagt max wir geben dir acht millionen dafür wenn uns die rechte dafür gibt es ja dann
Bei sowas meine ich ja dann würde ich dann würde ich was in der richtung machen
allerdings
Wie gesagt ich muss ich muss halt ehrlich sagen das ist das einzige was mich allgemein nützlich so interessiert
das einzige was mich irgendwie so
So wie soll so sozial allgemein nützlich interessiert ich will nichts spenden für irgendwelche menschen menschen gehen mir am arsch vorbei
Das einzige was mir persönlich am herzen liegen würde wer tatsächlich bessere bedingungen für tierheimtiere
Das ist wahrscheinlich echt das einzige was ich von der kohle so gemeinnützig machen würde
Also wenn ich wirklich richtig krass geld hätte also ich meine ich spende ja jetzt schon einen die ein oder andere sache also ist es
Nicht aber wenn ich so richtig krass geld hätte dann würde ich irgendwas in der richtung recht machen
deschdachs gibt es den channel noch
tatsächlich
Weil alter wie viele leute gucken das mittlerweile
Das gucken die leute doch zur entspannung und zum schlafen oder
Zu nature sounds und da kann man gut pennen bei oh nein mail leak
By the way das ist was ich habe die e-mail nie bestätigt oder was okay nice
Ja also das ist eine e-mail die ich mir extra für den twitch fake account gemacht habe
Ganz ehrlich keine ahnung aber im ernst ich würde mich nicht auf irgendwelches alle legacy zeug
Spezialisieren
Also das hat also erstens weißt du nicht wie das so in zukunft weiterläuft es ist ja jetzt schon legacy und außerdem muss
Du dich fragen hast du wirklich bock hauptberuflich cobalt zu machen ernsthaft
Hast du deine e-mail alle in einem account oder hast du mehrere
Wie meinst du dass ich habe ich habe total viele total viele e-mail e-mail adressen
Also ein vorteil von so unsinnig viele domains zu besitzen ist
Dass man automatisch auch auf jeder domain genau so viele unsinnige e-mail adressen anlegen kann
Ach so meinst du das
Nee also für diese ganzen fake e-mail adressen habe ich ein e-mail account auf denen ich die sachen hin weiter leite
Die kommen nicht auf meinen main e-mail account raus und auch nicht auf meinem youtube e-mail account aber ich habe ein e-mail account
Bei gmail auf die auf die das weitergeleitet wird von diesen ganzen
Fake e-mail adressen das ist aber sette hast du die nicht gespeichert hat ein flash hat ein flash irgendwie probleme
Ja auf c++ entwickler sein hätte ich auch keinen bock
Ja das dumme ist
Ich habe zurzeit noch so einen ganz ganz alten stromzähler
Und die kann man nicht gescheit auslesen elektronisch guck mal so ein ding habe ich noch
Ich habe zwar auch noch einen zweiten aber der erfasst nicht das ganze haus
Der andere ist schon ein bisschen modern also ein ding habe ich noch und das kann man nicht gescheit auch mit diesen dingern das
Funktioniert nicht ich habe das ausprobiert leute wir haben sogar im stream mit so einem led line sensor
Das ausprobiert das ist der fall ist also das funktioniert das auslesen dieser scheibe
Aber halt nicht zuverlässig genug ich würde mal sagen es funktioniert in 90 95 prozent der fällen richtig
Aber das reicht halt auf dauer nicht um ordentlichen stromverbrauch auszulesen
Also ihr seht ja diese dinger sind so alt die haben keine
Irgendwie elektronische schnitte wenn du glück hast hast du welche die blinken falls die blinken ja
Wenn du welche hast die blinken dann ist dann ist alles gut aber den den ich habe der macht halt gar nichts
Der da dreht sich da dreht sich einfach nur
Und die einzige chance die du hast ist das irgendwie optisch auszulesen
und das funktioniert halt
Ja schon ziemlich unzuverlässig
Die alten müssen doch auch irgendwann ausgetauscht und ja bis jetzt hat sich bei mir noch keiner gemeldet dass die austauschen wollen
Auf die einen balkon gehabt ich habe noch nicht mal ein balkon
Aber ich kann ich kann es ja auch ich kann ja auch ich kann es ja auch auf die terrasse machen nämlich auf die terrasse auf den
auf die garage oder
Auf das dach von vom stall oder so
Ja da muss der elektriker kommen lassen und so da habe ich da habe ich kein bock drauf also ich hoffe die tauschen in irgendwann
demnächst mal aus
Und dann lese ich den aus dann ist ganz einfach dann ist da so eine led dran die pulst alle 0,8
Wattstunden und dann kann man das easy mit einem so einem fotoresistor auslesen und im esp 32
Also verpasst hast mich hat jemand gefragt ob ich schon mal versucht hat mein stromzähler auszulesen und das ist meine antwort darauf dass es
nicht richtig geht mit diesen diggern
das funktioniert das funktioniert wahrscheinlich noch unzuverlässiger
Ich weiß dass es so projekte gibt dass sogar mit dem esp 32 funktioniert
aber da habe ich das problem in meinem
Schaltschrank unten im keller ist der abstand nicht groß genug dass die kamera scharf das fokussieren kann
doch kann ich aber da muss ich mir elektriker holen der mir noch einen zusätzlichen einbaut oder die mit den startwerken stattwerken was ausmachen oder
Keine ahnung habe ich kein bock drauf ich warte einfach bis sie von sich aus auf die idee kommen
So akut ist es jetzt nicht wie gesagt ich hatte schon die idee ob ich nicht selbst ob ich nicht auslese mit so einem
er line sensor
ja
so ein ding
Mit so einem ding kannst du die sachen auslesen guckt er hat hier so eine
Infrarot led und hier so ein infrarot empfänger und dann dann erkennst du quasi
Also bekommst du hier als signale raus kriegst analogen digital signal dann kannst du das ding also einstellen weil die scheibe
die scheibe die hier vorne durchläuft
die hat ja unterschiedliche farben die ist weiß und bei einem tick quasi ist sie rot oder
Ja oder halt irgendwie eine andere farbe und das erkennst du mit so einem sensor anhand so von von dem analog output
oder wenn du das auch vom digital output wenn es ordentlich eingestellt hast
das funktioniert schon prinzipiell die auszulesen aber es ist halt einfach zu fehleranfällig sagt
ich warte bis sie das auswechseln fertig
Schon spät ja leute ich gehe jetzt auch ins bett bin
müde
war heute eher laberstreben als amazon einkauf streben aber eine sache hat sich schon mal auf jeden fall richtig gelohnt
ich weiß dass ich firmware update von meiner ssd machen muss das war mir im vorfeld gar nicht klar
gut dass wir mal drüber geredet haben chat
warum release samsung denn so ein shit überhaupt
ja schauen wir mal
wir sehen uns macht's gut bis morgen vielleicht
wahrscheinlich
bis dann